uh speaking of pitching yaw the thing uh
so Starship flips on its belly flops
there's a interesting kind of maneuver
uh on the way down to land uh can you
describe that maneuver what's involved
there yeah so this is definitely a first
I don't think anything's tried Landing
like this before but the idea is
when you're falling through the
atmosphere the atmosphere could actually
do a lot of work for you you know you're
moving quickly something is falling from
space there's a lot of energy involved
you have a really good video on this as
well
and uh thank you
um the uh as it's falling you know you
can you let the you want to let the
atmosphere do as much work as it can and
so
um if you have a uh unsymmetric you know
it's not a ball that's falling this is
some kind of object with with shape some
you know at one face of it is going to
have more surface area than the other
face so you know in the shape of like a
cylinder if you're falling you know like
a soda can if you're falling top or
bottom first it's a certain amount of
surface area if you flip that on its
side you actually have a lot more
surface area so with the same exact
vehicle you can actually have a lot more
drag you can actually slow it down a lot
more using the exact same like same
atmosphere same same vehicle just by
turning at 90 degrees you can slow it
down substantially like three or four
times slower
so that's energy that you don't have to
use anywhere else you don't have to use
an engine to slow you down you don't
have to do anything else so SpaceX
realized okay if we flip this thing on
its side and let it fall like a skydiver
almost you know instead of like pencil
diving into the pool you're belly
flopping
you're maximizing the amount of surface
area that's in the Windstream that's
being slowed down
but obviously like in order to land
especially if you're SpaceX and you know
elon's obsessed with like not having
different parts you know he wants the
best part is no part so if you're going
to land with the engines you might as
well use engines that you've already
have the engines that are you know used
for the other portions of flight so you
kick those on and you use those engines
to actually turn it 90 degrees from
belly flopping to feet first
and that way you can use those same
engines to land and you don't have to
have like auxiliary Landing engines you
don't have to have forces you know even
if you were to land like on its belly
with a separate set of engines Not only
would those engines weigh a lot you know
and be extra complexity etc etc but you
also don't have to make the ship be able
to handle Landing you know like on its
belly as opposed to having the forces be
vertical through it but it's a giant
thing you have to rotate in the air huge
and uh as you also highlight you know
there's liquid fuel slushing around in
the tank so like you can't uh I guess
use that fuel directly after another
kind of fuel like there's just
complexities there yeah that involve uh
plus the actual maneuver is difficult
from the like like what are the
thrusters that actually make that make
all that happen you're you're adding a
lot of
complexity uh not a lot but your
complexity to the maneuver and
possibility where failure Could Happen
uh in order to sort of save in order for
the air to do uh some of the work so
what is some of that complexity just you
can Linger on it you know if you if you
think about what it's going to take to
go from horizontal to Vertical
um this rocket in particular that
Starship has these big flaps
um so it has kind of two nose flaps and
two uh rearward flaps the river flaps
are a lot bigger because the majority of
the the mass the engines and stuff are
in the back of the the vehicle so in
order to kind of be stable and they just
fold themselves inwards like on their
dihedral angle at a dihedra angle in
order to
increase or decrease the drag so you can
control its all three axes of control
while it's falling
um you know on its belly you can control
it that way using these four different
fins so you have these giant moving
surfaces that take thousands of of
horsepower or just insane amount of
torque in order to move these quickly
enough to be a valid control surface so
that's a huge complication is moving
these fins and developing that that
Landing algorithm and the you know the
control for a huge vehicle with flaps
going like you know in and out in and
out in and out to stay stable then right
as you light the engines now all of a
sudden you want the top you know you
want to flip the rocket 90 degrees so
the rearward flaps the bottom flaps fold
in they tuck all the way into minimize
drag that's going to make it want to you
know swing down you extend the upper
flaps that makes it so the nose wants to
pitch up you kick on the engines
um they're now lighting all three
engines at least as of the last like
successful attempts they like all three
of the sea level Raptor engines and
they're pitched all the way like you
know 10 or 15 degrees or whatever the
maximum pitch is on them and that
induces a you know it does that kick
maneuver to kick it over from horizontal
to vertical now the problem is you lit
your engines while you're horizontal so
they put some horizontal velocity into
the rocket they push the rocket you know
at the time the nose is at the time of
lighting those engines the nose is
facing the Horizon and the engines are
facing the opposite Horizon yeah see now
shot at a decent amount and often you
know the direction that you're not
falling you know
um so you have to factor that in to
where you're Landing because you're
going to land on this precise in this
case you're going to land on the inside
the arm the loving arms of the
Chopsticks you know the Creed Arms Wide
Open you know try to land inside this
exactly the song they're playing through
my head as I watch this now thank you
thank you for forever joining those two
I appreciate this and you have to very
precisely control so what you have to do
is now that it's done that kick you also
have to cancel out that horizontal
velocity so it's actually going to
rotate Beyond 90 degrees to cancel out
that horizontal velocity
and then modulate the engines to make it
so the thrust you know is is perfect
so that it can control itself into a
controlled landing and all this is done
in like 500 meters like 1500 feet you
know you're doing all of those things
stupidly close to the ground it looks
absurd so far they've done five of these
tests
all um the first four all blew up you
know um they're all coming in from about
10 kilometers or 33 000 feet
um falling flipping you know again this
thing is huge that just the booster or
just the upper stage of this
um is is like 50 meters tall you know so
it's 150 well it's like 45 meter about
50 meters tall about 165 feet tall 9
meters wide so 30 feet wide it weighs
you know something like God I don't
remember if it's something like 120
metric tons so 120 000 kilograms you
know two quarter of a million pounds
empty and it's doing this flip maneuver
and it has to do all this perfectly so
the first four four attempts of this
were pretty spectacular failures so just
to clarify which stage is doing this
maneuver it's the upper stage it's doing
this belly flop maneuver yep uh so this
is the the stage that would presumably
um have humans on board if we were to
use
um uh if things continue to plan now
here's here's something I would love to
see yeah just saying this yeah if you
already have these big Arrow surfaces
the flaps they also have to move they're
on heavy Motors and hinges and flaps and
all that stuff I'm actually surprised
that for Earth
they aren't just looking at Landing it
horizontally on a Runway like the space
shuttle
oh
I mean interesting that worked the brand
did it you know the Soviet Union's put
on I rolled my arm real hard there sorry
thank you wow wow really good I'm very
impressed and uh you know the Branded it
do we have other space planes like the
X-37B uh we have the upcoming Sierra
Nevada's Dream Chaser uh it's yeah you
have some extra mass in the wings but so
does Starship Starship has the extra
mass of those flaps and you know the the
motors and the hinges and all that stuff
I I would like to see the trade on like
is it actually lighter weight
to do that versus doing what SpaceX is
doing
so yeah I mean that's that's the funny
thing I think realistically if Elon
walks in the door tomorrow and says guys
we did some simulations and actually
it's like we can get another 5 000
kilograms into space if we just land it
horizontal if we kind of give up on our
ego and land horizontally at least on
Earth
then you know I think they could be
doing that pretty quickly because that's
the thing is uh this ultimate thing has
been to land on Mars and you know other
planets and Mars doesn't have a Runway
doesn't have a you know thick enough
atmosphere to utilize aerodynamic flight
like that so you have to do propulsive
Landing for Mars
um you're going to land on an unprepared
surface you know so it has to be able to
do this at some point the ultimate it
sounds ridiculous and it is but the
ultimate goal of it is to land on Mars
there's not much of an atmosphere to
like to help you with the for the belly
fat to be useful there's only one
percent the atmosphere on Mars as there
is on Earth but you still want to
utilize as much of that atmosphere as
possible so in the upper atmosphere it's
still going to be coming in more or less
uh kind of perpendicular to the
Airstream I guess it's probably more
like you know 60 degrees 70 degrees to
the Airstream like where it's belly
flopping and it's gonna especially do
that on Mars it's going to need to you
know use up as let the little bit of
atmosphere there is you know you're
coming in at insane velocities and so
even that one percent thin atmosphere is
still going to do a lot of work now on
Mars there's only 38 of Earth's gravity
on Mars so the belly flop maneuver is a
lot it could be a lot more conservative
you could do that at like 5000 feet up
and it just wouldn't matter as much
because there's not as much gravity loss
or gravity drag so you can kind of just
more more slowly gently you know you
don't have to do this crazy extravagant
like belly flop you know flip maneuver
but it would still something at some
point you would transition from more or
less perpendicular to the Airstream to
you know horizontal to Landing
vertically I like how we're having this
old boring conversation about the
differences of landing on Earth versus
on Mars
uh this is surreal that this is actually
a real conversation that uh this is
something that we're discussing yeah
because it has to do both yeah
but in my opinion yes I think we'll
pretty quickly see an evolution of
Starship that's like dedicated versions
for certain tasks sure and at the end of
the day again if if it's if someone runs
a simulation says it's actually more
efficient and it's better just to land
horizontally on a Runway then that's
what's gonna happen you know it it
doesn't matter but they still will
develop you know if the ultimate goal is
to land on Mars and they'll have a
dedicated Mars variant you know which
will likely look different than the
earth variant you know and they'll still
probably be launched on the same booster
you know what I mean so there's Oh you
mean like that particular vehicle will
not be returning back to Earth it'll
need to be modified because uh because
the ultimate is to have one Starship to
goes to Mars lands on Mars and takes off
of Mars lands back on Earth and is
reused again yeah over and over and over
and there's a chance that you you know
you have just a cycler just a you know
if you're if you at the end of the day
you're just really trying to see what is
most feasible what's the most efficient
you literally have a vehicle dedicated
to Mars Mars it's easy to do a single
stage to orbit it's a lot lower gravity
a lot thinner atmosphere you can easily
do a single stage orbit you get into
orbit you park to a dedicated you know
transfer vehicle that goes between Earth
and Mars it only stays in space you
don't have heat shields you don't have
Landing Lakes you don't have all these
things that you need and ideally it's
nuclear powered so it's super efficient
that gets you back to earth once you're
at Earth you Rendezvous again with
another Landing Starship and that
Starship might be horizontal Runway
Starship you know like yeah there's no I
I don't see the and I think ultimately
it'll win out where we don't have a one
size fits all I think that's that's the
flaw of the Space Shuttle really is that
it was trying to do everything and I
ended up kind of doing nothing well but
that's I think what SpaceX has proven I
mean SpaceX already has variants coming
there's already going to be a dedicated
lunar lander for NASA for the Artemis
program there's already going to be a
tanker variant there's already going to
be likely just a pure cargo version
there's likely going to be a human
version we'll likely see evolutions of
this thing happen you know relatively
quickly
and one once it's all working it's only
a matter of weeks before people riding
on it will be complaining about the
speed of the Wi-Fi
as the old like uh Lucy K joke with like
where you're flying on a chair through
the air it's incredible you didn't even
know this existed and now you're
complaining about it oh that's great
exactly uh so you yeah you tweeted fun
fact about Starship by doing the flip
around 500 meters versus higher up like
two two thousand meters the difference
in Delta V is 500 meters per second
that's a 20 ton fuel saving which means
basically 20 tons more you can put into
orbit that's more than uh Falcon 9 has
ever launched just by flipping later
that's really interesting so there that
that was a decision too to flip close to
the ground yeah yeah be closer to the
ground the better the more again the
more the atmosphere is doing work and uh
you know we get into that video really
dives into like gravity losses and
gravity drag the more time you're spent
every every second that your rocket
engine is running Earth is stealing 9.8
meters per second of acceleration
against you there's just inherently 9.8
meters per second squared of
acceleration so every second that engine
is running
the first a big majority of your thrust
is actually being just stolen by Earth's
gravity well
so if you're the longer you're fighting
that the more inefficient it is so ID I
mean the best thing would be you flip at
you know 100 meters off the ground you
light all your engines to maximum thrust
you pull 50 G's you know you land on a
dime basically obviously there's no
margin there there's you know and
there's diminishing returns on that that
gravity loss thing in your high thrust
weight ratios so that's a pretty good
compromise like yes it looks scary but
they could be a lot more aggressive with
that yet and squeeze out even a little
bit better performance but there are
diminishing returns so that's kind of
the magic number we've seen so far today
but we'll likely see that you know be
played with